and uh the first thing i want to do is
we got to talk about this young woman
and we got to talk about you know
trump's been suspended there's just
there's just so much going on we'll just
try to get through it
but this is the most important story
this is from wusa9
woman shot inside u.s u.s capitol
building during riot dies from injuries
it is not known yet what exactly led to
the shooting a photo shows law
enforcement with guns drawn inside the
lockdown house chamber
they say dc's mayor muriel bowser and
police chief robert conte iii also
confirmed
that a person was shot inside the
capitol building but did not release
much more details
in the news conference at 5 p.m the
behavior we are witnessing is shameful
unpatriotic and above all it is unlawful
anyone who engages in these activities
continues to engage in this
in these activities will be held
accountable said bowser
a lockdown was in place wednesday
afternoon for the u.s capitol building
uh and it has been lifted according to
officials but there's still a curfew
right understanding is there
it started at 6 p.m earliest one i can
remember yeah curfew earliest
6 p.m curfew this is not on a weekday
yeah
they say u.s park police d.c police and
national guard troops
have worked to move trump supporters and
rioters gathered gathered at the steps
of the us capitol building
to create a safety perimeter tear gas
and percussion grenades
have been deployed by police around the
u.s capitol to move back rioters
it is not known yet what exactly led to
the one being shot but a photo from cbs
news's zac
hudak shows law enforcement with guns
drawn inside the house chamber
around 2 46 pm after riders broke into
the u.s capitol building
u.s capitol police ordered the capitol
lockdown around 2 30 p.m on wednesday
and evacuations of two capital campus
buildings the library of congress james
madison memorial building
and the cannon house office building as
protests raged at the capitol complex
shortly after president trump addressed
his voters vowing never to concede
the election in a speech on the ellipse
large crowds of pro-trump protesters
marched to the u.s capitol
and squared off with capitol police
protesters broke through several
uh barriers placed at the steps of the
capitol while the certification of
electoral college votes began inside
and then as you all as many of you
probably already know if you don't they
suspended they recessed the joint
session of congress
joe manchin said that these thugs will
not stop us from counting
the the votes and that they're planning
on going back in as soon as the
buildings are secure
i don't there's there's blood on the
ground there's a woman who died
and they're going to go back in and
they're going to finish in many places
than one there there's blood and my news
team actually sent me
the video of the shooting and before the
shooting and it looks like people just
milling around now of course you don't
see
who shot you don't see it in exact
frame with this allegedly now we're
getting information a 16 year old
girl that was there but you hear the
shot and it's extremely graphic and
you see the life literally leave her
eyes so it's extremely intense and right
now on twitter there's many hashtags
that are trending one of them is white
privilege
and a lot of people are saying look how
favorable these protesters were treated
right now protesters are actually
engaged with conflicts with the police
there and a lot of left
leaning kind of thinkers in the
mainstream media are saying look these
protesters were treated
favorably but we have an unarmed 16 year
old girl
shot and killed today that's something
that's that's something incredibly
important
something that needs to be investigated
something that there needs to be justice
behind
just like any death that leads to a
police officer shooting something
or doing something that that leads to an
end of a life
which is absolutely insane she was in
the front by the way
no she wasn't she was standing like
right at the door and then she got hit
and got knocked back onto the ground
i didn't see that that's a video on
twitter i'm looking for it right now i'm
gonna retweet it uh the video i saw
there's there's like one guy wearing a
poofy jacket in the front and one guy's
like his hands up and then he backs up
against the wall
then someone walks in front of the
camera and the woman is further back
okay i don't know i don't know yeah i'll
pull it up but
all of twitter about to become a cab
you've been feeling it over the last few
days anyway
sentiment has definitely been turning
it's almost like an instantaneous
network
shift where the whole right network just
was like all of a sudden
blue blue lives whatever yeah seriously
whatever
i push back on that on my twitter i mean
i support the police in dc they usually
do a tremendous job under very very
difficult
they're difficult did you see the video
of what happened today i did but i don't
have any other information and i also
has anybody matched up a shot of the
police from the outside and the the
people on the inside
like a picture yeah yeah i think i think
we've seen pictures of of guns drawn
inside the chamber there's there's video
of the people inside the doors
there's video of the other people that's
pulling the trigger but no
nobody shot into the chamber i
understand that
they shot from inside the chamber no one
knows all the video is you saw the video
people are milling about
and then you hear the shot right but
where was that door leaving those are my
questions where is that door that
they're like
one thing that's also into the main
chamber where the guys have their guns
at the door
there wasn't a rush there wasn't a fight
there wasn't a conflict it's literally
people milling about like they were even
in an elevator
so so that's another thing to really
well the window was broken yeah yeah
yeah
and then they barricaded the door it
looked like there was a pause i want to
say too there's no confirmation yet that
she was 16.
yeah i've seen this this is according to
the cpac
that just released this information and
there are some high profile blue check
individuals saying a 16 year old girl
died but
i think i saw jack vasovic maybe
somebody else comparing the images from
the
the officers with the guns drawn to the
scene where people were the one was shot
and like pointing out differences in the
door and that it wasn't the same door
really and that it might have been
somewhere else i i can't confirm that
it's just something i saw in the past
yeah because the windows looked the same
i could be wrong though you know
whenever it comes to big breaking
stories like this uh details come out
usually get corrected later on
and then people i mean it always happens
but then people might say like but hold
on
on the day of they reported this that
and this and then it changes like well
yeah
in this case though no no relevant
detail is going to change except for the
fact that
the story will be maga fascist storm the
capital
girl gets killed attack police
insurrection
etc etc well watching cnn before this
broadcast they were trying to kind of
obfuscate that and make it not a big
deal
they were more they were more talking
about look the members of congress were
terrified and they were focusing
on that and then they kind of mentioned
in passing there was also a protester
shot and killed
in other news in other news look how and
then it was just
extremely eye-opening to see cnn the
network that just a few weeks ago
was telling you on national television
that protests are not supposed to be
peaceful
literally lose their ish today talking
about insurgencies
terrorists and this extremely warfaric
kind of language trying to deem what
they saw today as the worst possible
thing in the world now again it wasn't
nice it wasn't good
obviously there was a lot of turmoil
obviously there was a lot of chaos
there's a lot of confusion we're still
finding out exactly what happened about
this event
but this is the same network again
during the summer when similar events
were happening
all throughout the country they were
supporting it and cheering it on
so yeah let me show you let's pull up
this photo real quick this is from i
just pulled it up on google images from
today
and it says members of i believe it's
members of congress being given
gas masks there are these like plastic
bags you put over your head with a
filtration system
i think one of the craziest things i
have ever heard in my life
tear gas fired in the rotunda tell me
man i mentioned mustard gas yesterday i
was kind of half joking but it can get
super extreme when chaos strikes well
listen listen
when you fire tear gas indoors people
die
it displaces oxygen i have seen people
catches on fire
when you're jammed together in a crowd
you're basically indoors like in waco
well no in crowds the air clears quickly
people disperse
if you can disperse if you can't though
it's a different story sure but
if you've ever been locked
shoulder-to-shoulder pressed and you
can't move you're just being moved with
the clutch so when i was in town
when i was in turkey during the gezi
park protests
there's istaklau which is this big
corridor of uh shopping markets
uh it's it's a big shopping street it's
amazing really
and this is in this this is in uh uh
istanbul and when they start firing tear
gas like crazy
you can't go anywhere you're you're
you're in this corridor and you're
trying to run
out and the gas doesn't dissipate
because the buildings are all by your
side so that i get
but when you're inside a building you
know what we ended up seeing people were
running into parking garages
and then then you're you're sealed in
perfectly when the tear gas went in
people just started dropping to the
ground
because they're not breathing air
anymore you're breathing in tear gas
you can't breathe once it gets in your
lungs your lungs constrict you struggle
and
hit the ground and then people started
running in with masks and pulling out
bodies of unconscious people
when they said they tear gas the rotunda
i was just like
dude people are gonna die now nobody i
don't think anybody died
from that we did see some people get
carried out but
somebody died from taking a bullet now
now here's the thing luke is wearing a
very interesting t-shirt
well i've been i've been selling this
t-shirt for about over a year now i've
been i've been talking about this for i
think
i can't even i can't even understand how
long i've been talking about this but
i've been talking about this
hyper uh partisan this hyper this
sensationalism
bull crap that people call news that
again is just weaponized information
meant so people fight each other and now
we're here at this crescendo and i think
this is only the beginning of a lot of
more horrible things to come in my
opinion definitely well
so the shirt luke is wearing is that
it's the guy poking meme
and he says come on do a civil war and
it's the donkey and the elephant
and the guy is abc fox cbs cnn the
reason why this is important let me let
me show you this uh
from cnn trump caused this insurrection
and every republican must condemn it
they're calling it an insurrection on uh
on tv i hate when this happens well the
former president george w
bush also written just just released a
very strong statement calling this an
insurrection
george w bush it's an insurrection
that's what cnn has said
uh fox news is calling it a protest
after they cleared out the capital
people were still
pushing they were still fighting tear
gas was still being deployed
and thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim
cast irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you